-Our first guest tonight
is a very talented actress
and director.
She directs and stars in
"What Happens Later,"
which is in theaters
November 3rd.
Let's take a look.
-Well, I always wondered
why you left.
-No, you didn't.
-Yeah.
-We talked about it all
before I left Madison.
We sat in the back booth
at Morty's
over our fries and beers,
and we very mature,
very civilized about it.
Did a whole postmortem.
Come on.
You know that's true.
-No.
When people break up,
there's the thing
that they tell each other,
they tell their friends
and then --
then there's the truth.
-Please welcome to the show.
Meg Ryan, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I am so happy
to have you here.
-Hi, Seth.
-This is a thrill for me.
This is also very exciting.
You don't just star
in this film.
You wrote
and directed this film.
-Yeah.
-How did this story
first come to you?
-Well, it was a play that the
playwright did a first draft of,
and I -- it was during Covid,
and I had a lot of time,
and I just started writing,
and I kept writing
and I kept writing.
And at like 5:00 in the morning
I'd get more ideas
and more ideas.
David Duchovny is in the movie
with me, too,
and he came on board.
We started, you know, sort of
circling the story together,
and suddenly we were financed.
And now here we are.
It was all like --
like happenstance, it felt like.
-Did you -- when you
originally had the idea,
you weren't planning
on playing the part?
Is that correct?
-No, no.
-And then once you were
playing the part,
how important was it for you
to find a David Duchovny?
-There's just two people
in the movie.
-Yeah, well, there you go?
-That's it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So I had to have a partner,
and he is so,
you know,
there's just no one like him.
-He's really unique.
He was here yesterday
and he's been here a bunch,
and I really love him
because I just can't predict
what he's going to say.
-No, or how
he's going to say it.
-Yeah.
-Like, how he's going to say,
and I think
the clo-- the closest
comparable person
is like Walter Matthau, I mean,
in the best possible way.
Like, he can spin a line,
he can break your heart,
he can make you laugh.
He -- and he's a great partner,
you know?
And really, we had each other
and he had a lot of patience.
He took, like,
a big chance with me.
I'm like a second time director
and he's, you know,
he's the person
we all know and love.
-And he, yeah.
-Was he worried
that you weren't going to pay
any attention to him
because you were also
in the movie?
-Because I was in the movie?
-As a director, he's like,
I'm worried that you
as a director
are going to pay
no attention to me.
-I thought that was a little,
maybe a little bit of a worry.
But I have to say, like,
we didn't have playback
while we were shooting,
we weren't able to look.
-So you weren't watching.
You would shoot a scene,
and you wouldn't be able to go
and watch it, right?
-No, no, so in the edit room,
I was like,
"Who's that blonde like blob in
the movie with David Duchovny?"
[ Laughter ]
So he had nothing
to worry about.
-He was telling us that you
shot in a working airport,
mostly at night
when nobody was there,
but you also had to face
the challenges of daytime
when there were
actually travelers.
-Yes, we had
real travelers who really
didn't care at all about us.
-Yeah.
This big apparatus,
all this light,
all this -- all this commotion.
And they didn't --
they didn't care much,
but it made us
have to be on our toes.
We did eight minute long takes,
which for a movie actor,
you just don't do that.
-Yeah.
-So, and the great thing about
shooting in an airport at night
is that, well, eventually
no one's there.
-Yeah.
-So we just felt like
we had the place to ourselves.
We made a movie
kind of in secret,
and now it's just like, weird
feeling putting a movie out.
It's like sending
your first born child out,
like, or your
or your oddest child out.
[ Laughter ]
And just saying, "You just go be
yourself, honey."
-We thought you'd stay at home,
but you are going
to go out in the world.
-Time to just go
out there and be yourself.
-This is your second film
you've directed.
Is there -- is there some
element of filmmaking
that you enjoy
the most that surprised you?
-Well, you're just in on it
with everybody,
which is great
because you're working with
all these different kinds
of brands of artists,
these, you know,
masters of light and sound,
and your senses become
very like, heightened,
you know, like it's
a heightened sensory experience
and you're in on it
with the other actors.
And a lot of times
you're just -- you just
know your own process,
you know?
But this -- this way,
you're just -- you're,
I don't know, you've just got
a secret with everybody.
-I've always been so impressed
when I stopped by sets,
when friends of mine
are directing a film,
there's just a thousand
choices a day.
Like, that's the part
you underestimate
is you think a director
is just focused on the words
and these two great actors,
and then someone comes over
with like 30 spoons
and they're like,
"Which spoon?"
-And, yeah, you could --
-Yeah.
-You're right.
And this was like
I directed --
There I am, like, I --
I had to do so much,
I had to be so concentrated.
I had to really prepare,
prepare, prepare, prepare.
I was there for
five weeks beforehand.
And then really it was
so I could just not think
about it with David,
so I could just
kind of be loose.
And my character
is like a, you know,
she's just a woo-woo,
very flaky person.
And as a -- and as a director,
you have to really micromanage.
So I kind of -- every time
they said action,
I was like, "Alright,
like, I'm just going
to relax a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
Just be here with Mr. Duchovny."
-You dedicated this film
to Nora Ephron,
who obviously is a director
you worked
with quite famously
to great result.
What did you learn
most from her?
Because obviously
you've done films
with so many different
kinds of directors.
-From her,
I just learned the pure delight.
She had pure delight
in moviemaking.
And the the thing about writing
and directing is that,
you know, the words come
to you in a -- it's so private.
You know, your home, like,
it's 5:00 in the morning
and you run the scene in your
head and you write it down,
and then all of a sudden
you cut to the set
and there's 150 people who care
about bringing that to life
and have opinions about that,
and it's a joyful thing.
And she had like the joy of
giving this great dinner party
every time you were on.
The sets with her
were really fun.
-That's great.
-I heard Hugh Grant
say one time,
I didn't personally hear it,
but I read that he said doing
a comedy is like being a balloon
in a world of pins.
-Uh-huh.
-That's true.
And you just don't want the set
to be a world of pins.
-Yeah, that's a
good way of looking.
You -- you --
It's trick or treating.
It's It's Halloween,
it's New York City.
I actually have a son who's
going to be a vampire today.
-Oh, you do?
-A five-year-old son
is going to be a vampire.
This is your son, Jack.
-Yes.
-When he was six?
-He was about six years old.
-And this is, obviously,
he has --
he comes
from show business stock.
His makeup is that good?
-Yeah.
He was so interested.
He was very --
-My five-year-old
looks like [bleep]
compared to him.
[ Laughter ]
I should know your son,
Jack Quaid, he's a great actor.
He's also been a guest
on the show.
I'm a big fan of his, we are.
-He's so funny.
This -- he wanted --
he wanted to be Dracula,
but then he told me
like he want --
he had a name and he wanted
to be Count Jackula.
-Count Jackula?
-Yeah.
--I was like, no, man.
You just have to trust me
on this one.
-They're already like
seven of those on the subway.
-No, no.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't --
and they don't like...
-You don't do that.
[ Applause ]
-Congratulations on the film.
It has just been so wonderful
having you here.
Please come back soon.
-Thank you.
-You guys, Meg Ryan.
"What Happens Later"
is in theatres Friday.
We'll be right back
with Caitlin Collins.